avoir 20 ans cette semaine ça sent les
festivals d'été ça sent la fête de la
musique et les livres de plage on va pas
parler de vacances on va parler de
culture on va débattre de culture sur ce
plateau et entretenir la culture du
débat en croisant les points de vue et
surtout en essayant de ne pas opposer
les anciens et les modernes sur cette
question de la culture et pour ça j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir isole tout jasm
bonjour vous avez 25 ans vous vivez à
Paris mais vous avez grandi à Sarcelles
vous êtes titulaire d'un master de
travail politique et parlementaire et
vous avez eu la révélation de la culture
des lieux le lycée s'est passé pour vous
par l'histoire de l'art et vous avez
aussi travaillé en Licence sur l'accès à
la culture selon la couleur politique
des collectivités à côté de vous Jul
comme César bonjour c'est le nom de
votre compte Instagram qui compte près
de 100000 followers vous partagez vos
goûts en matière de culture de livres
d'expo vous appelez Jules stimfling et
vous êtes aussi cofondateur du média le
crayon un média de débat des jeunes et
vous êtes auparavant passé par Sciences
Po merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur
ce plateau face à vous Armel Stepien
vous avez peut-être rencontré je la
Science Po non
vous y enseignez en tout cas la science
peau depuis une dizaine d'années sur les
pratiques culturelles sur les politiques
publiques dans le domaine de la culture
et vous êtes aussi et surtout
responsable des relations publiques et
des actions culturelles à la Maison de
la poésie à Paris enfin François Cusset
sur ce plateau bonjour et bienvenue
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes historiens des idées professeur de
civilisation américaine à l'Université
de Paris Nanterre et dernièrement vous
avez publié ce tract chez Gallimard la
haine de l'émancipation debout la
jeunesse du monde vous parlez notamment
du walkisme comme d'un fétiche politique
un épouvantail brandit par les forces
réactionnaires pour refuser les combats
de la jeunesse voilà qui va faire des
bas sur ce plateau mais d'abord et bien
on va s'intéresser à ce que Lise à ce
qui coûte les jeunes
quelle culture plébiscitent-ils on va
commencer cette émission une fois n'est
pas coutume par le bilan le bilan du
Pass Culture qui permet depuis 2021 aux
jeunes de 18 ans d'avoir 300 euros à
dépenser dans les offres culturelles de
leur choix Audrey
définir pour leurs 18 ans Emma et Zoé à
droite ont reçu 300 euros de la part de
l'État elles ont deux ans pour utiliser
cet argent à leur guise mais via leur
passe culture on a juste donc par
exemple à choisir une offre et on a
juste à réserver et à confirmer la
réservation moi j'ai réservé donc les
solidaysa et on a un délai de 5 jours
nous pour annuler notre commande donc
c'est assez simple et c'est hyper rapide
à faire Zoé a donc choisi deux festivals
de musique sur plusieurs jours pour 230
euros
à dépensé pour le festival donc du coup
c'est hyper contente de pouvoir le page
culture pour pouvoir payer enfin pour
pouvoir y aller en fait parce que
j'adore ça les festivals arrivent
troisième sur le podium des offres
plébiscitées par les 18-20 ans derrière
le cinéma et la lecture Emma elle a fait
un choix bien différent j'ai choisi un
truc que je jouais depuis très longtemps
que je pouvais pas m'acheter parce que
c'est un peu cher dans le lot il y a un
micro il y a une tablette de mixage et
il y avait l'antipop donc qui servait à
pas faire de bruit derrière le micro bah
du coup tout ça je l'ai eu pour 300
euros donc j'ai mis tout l'argent dedans
c'est un choix que j'ai eu du mal à
faire mais je me suis dit que ça allait
les coups il y a des gens qui vont
penser que la culture c'est vraiment
quelque chose de scolaire ou littéraire
ou des choses comme ça pour moi la
culture c'est tant qu'on tant qu'on
s'instruis on sent qu'on s'instruit
et que c'est
utile pour nous je pense que l'on peut
appeler ça de la culture depuis sa
généralisation il y a deux ans la
manière d'utiliser le Pass à bien changé
après une déferlante manga à ses débuts
à l'époque je me souviens on téléphonait
à notre représentant achète et on lui
dit s'il te plaît envoie-nous tout de
suite cette série complète de One Piece
on va pas tenir sans ça il y a eu un
effet passe culture égale pas ce manga
l'utilisation du passé normalisé alors
on va vendre par exemple
des livres
à caractère scolaires ou universitaire
des grands classiques on vend de la
philo avec le Pass Culture on vend
Nietzsche le Gai Savoir on vend hops
mais pas que on a des jeunes
du 93 le plus souvent donc de chez nous
qui viennent en passe culture acheter
ces ouvrages là qui sont des ouvrages
trop chers celui-ci vaut 28,40 mais
grâce à ce dispositif ils peuvent les
acquérir et là c'est pas du tout pour
les études qui lisent cette
anthropologue et historien qui a
déconstruire les théories coloniales
c'est vraiment de l'intérêt
d'enrichissement personnel et culturel
c'est désormais les responsables du Pass
veulent faire en sorte que les jeunes
deviennent prescripteurs chaque semaine
plusieurs d'entre eux sont sélectionnés
pour faire des recommandations on a des
envoyés spéciaux qui finalement pendant
24 ou 48 heures ont le rôle d'un
journaliste notamment auprès d'un
festival et vont aller backstage
interviewer des techniciens interviewer
des artistes et faire des vidéos qui
peuvent être ensuite c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux
le Pass Culture il permet en fait à
beaucoup de lieux culturels dont le
public peut avoir tendance à vieillir de
créer une relation nouvelle avec les
jeunes beaucoup plus directs beaucoup
plus en dialogue avec eux et en fait de
s'adapter à la façon dont ils
fonctionnent quoi de mieux pour attirer
un public plus jeune que de demander un
peu d'aide aux principaux concernés
bon alors vous n'avez pas tout à fait 18
ans mais qu'est-ce que vous auriez
acheté l'un et l'autre si vous aviez eu
accès au Pass Culture à 18 ans isolt
mais je pense que à 18 ans on est assez
influencé parce qu'on apprend à l'école
par notre famille donc j'aurais eu
tendance peut-être à acheter un livre
dans mon réparer ma mère ou en cours
ouais les parents la famille déjà
prescriptrice
aujourd'hui
entre l'âge de 18 ans et l'âge de 25 ans
si ce n'est que j'aurais peut-être
investi plus dans les jeux vidéo
auxquels je joue moi aujourd'hui mais ça
fait débat ça au début il y en a
beaucoup qui ont dit avec le parce que
des mangas ou des jeux vidéo bon et
d'ailleurs on peut tout à fait discuter
de leur place dans la culture moi je
trouve que pour les mangas par exemple
c'est c'est un grand enrichissement que
d'avoir
en France le pays qui est le plus le
plus actif dans la culture manga après
les Japons dans le monde je trouve que
c'est c'est super on a des personnes qui
suivaient SNK qui suivent One Piece qui
suivent
un certain nombre d'univers
et qui ont pour ça une fascination pour
le Japon une ouverture à l'Asie une
ouverture aussi à une spiritualité une
cosmologie qui est différente de de
notre cosmologie européenne donc ça je
trouve ça super à titre personnel c'est
pas ce que moi je consomme je me serais
sans doute tourné plutôt vers quelques
livres place de cinéma et jeux vidéo et
300 euros
à 18 ans vous allez travailler notamment
sur
comment dire le fait qu'il puisse avoir
des freins territoriaux un inégal accès
à la culture
selon les départements on imagine que
c'est aussi selon les finances bien sûr
des uns et des autres je pense que c'est
une somme une somme importante c'est
surtout une somme que certains jeunes de
quartiers défavorisés n'auraient pas eu
de la part de leurs parents s'ils
avaient pas eu le Pass Culture donc je
pense que c'est important pour eux de se
dire à un moment donné on a les moyens
de s'acheter un instrument de musique on
a les moyens de s'acheter un livre et
d'éveiller une curiosité à la au monde
de la culture tandis que s'il y avait
pas eu ce Pass Culture il n'aurait pas
eu forcément l'occasion
d'avoir un instrument de musique tout
simplement et on loot trop peu souvent
les bonnes actions politiques je qui
sont mises en place je trouve qu'il faut
féliciter
ceux qui ont mis en place culture
ça fait des barres parce que François
Cusset vous êtes où un peu mitigé sur le
sur le Pass Culture pour quelle raison
d'abord il faut aborder tout ce sujet de
manière voilà critique il y a plein de
il y a plein de facteurs en jeu
évidemment qu'en soit attribué de
l'argent chez des jeunes qui a priori
n'en ont pas à leur choix d'achat
culturel et une bonne chose mais
justement en soi si c'est des couplets
d'un travail d'incitation que il y a pas
que l'État qu'il doit faire il faut pas
en France c'est trop la culture d'Etat
ça peut être une incitation de terrain
par les communautés etc à voilà une
diversité de de d'accès à la culture à
plein de cultures avec des populaires
agriculture commerciale avec culture
légitime alors effectivement et et même
si isolent beaucoup mieux utilisé que
certains aujourd'hui la tentation est
non seulement d'aller acheter des
gadgets plus qu'effectivement des œuvres
mais surtout
et c'est là que ma critique de passer
par des distributeurs culturels très
grand public des grandes compagnies de
musique ou de livres parce que les
mangas j'adore mais souvent c'est des
grandes maisons d'édition parfois c'est
des petits indépendants et donc
d'enrichir une industrie déjà très riche
c'est à dire qu'il faut aussi que le
Pass Culture permet aux jeunes de
relation avec une culture indépendante
c'est à dire à petit voilà un petit
niveau à petit de production qui a
besoin de cet argent donc à toutes ces
conditions là avec de l'éducation avec
un rapport aux indépendants oui mais si
c'est des couplets de tout ça ça
ressemble un peu à ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui justement par ce
gouvernement c'est-à-dire une culture
marchandisée qui va venir remplacer une
vraie politique culturelle ensemble
toute la question c'est est-ce que c'est
ça doit permettre de aux jeunes de
diversifier leur pratique culturelle ou
simplement les aider à payer celle de
leur choix et vous dites naturellement
c'est plutôt vers une culture
marchandisée faudrait pas opposer les
deux parce que sinon ça veut dire qu'on
leur fait pas confiance en on va leur
donner un pass Culture et puis je sais
pas quoi une des conseils si vous voulez
non c'est pas ça il faut absolument le
passement gaz c'est pas un problème
n'oublions pas que d'ailleurs pas par
hasard un député du rassemblement
national qui s'est énervé contre ça
pourquoi pas c'est une culture
passionnante effectivement une culture à
mettre au dessus
s'il n'y a pas ce travail d'incitation
et d'éducation à tout ce qui existe
culturellement effectivement les
lecteurs de manga qui ne lisent que des
mangas n'utiliseront leur passe que à
acheter des mangas vous avez d'ailleurs
parlez avec votre communauté on a vu que
quand même il peut y avoir des goûts
assez divers dans la dans la jeunesse en
tout cas dans la communauté qui vous
suit sur votre votre compte Instagram
Jules oui alors c'est vrai que moi je
touche une communauté sur les réseaux
sociaux Instagram et Tik Tok qui est
plutôt de jeunes adultes peut-être que
le public adolescent qui est la cible du
Pass Culture la première cible et un peu
plus difficile effectivement à
éduquer au classique de la littérature
ou à des pièces de théâtre de compagnie
indépendantes ou à l'Opéra c'est vrai
que moi je le ressens aussi il y a même
entre moi qui ai 25 ans et quelqu'un qui
en aurait 15 un petit un petit décalage
forcément
qui vient qui vient du milieu social qui
vient de la maturité qu'on en a qui
réglage de l'éducation et qui vient
aussi du fait que des jeunes adolescents
aujourd'hui ont grandi encore plus que
moi avec les réseaux sociaux et
l'attractivité qui exerce même cognitive
des vidéos Youtube des vidéos Tik Tok
sur un temps très saccadé et avec un
dynamisme très important rend plus
difficile d'assister à de l'Opéra ou du
théâtre et je pense je suis pas de
défavorable à l'idée de fléchés une
partie du Pass Culture vers des livres
du théâtre ou du spectacle vivant et
d'autres des festivals moi je trouve que
ça pourrait être une idée
il faut aussi noter que le Pass Culture
s'est répandu aussi dans les
établissements scolaires puisque
maintenant il peut être accessible pour
des pour des classes à partir de la 6ème
et donc par exemple à la Maison de la
Poésie on peut faire des sorties avec le
Pass Culture des écrivains peuvent se
rendre en classe aussi pour rencontrer
les élèves et donc des ateliers
et je pense que le mot clé c'est celui
de la complémentarité c'est à dire que
effectivement si on peut travailler nous
avec des enseignants ou bien des
éducateurs d'éducation populaire
éducation nationale pour permettre qu'il
y ait des rencontres qui se fassent
autour de l'écriture de la lecture alors
quand ils auront 18 ans peut-être qu'ils
pourront utiliser aussi le Pass
différemment ou avec une ouverture autre
mais c'est assez essentiel
je le disais on a demandé un peu votre
communauté d'intervenir pour participer
à ce débat l'enrichir aussi des points
de vue un peu plus variés moi ce qui m'a
frappé on leur a demandé un petit peu
leur goût en matière de culture c'est
qu'on voit des goûts très éclectiques
très différents alors j'en cite
quelques-uns alors il y a bisou je
m'envole qui dit littérature classique
polar sans humaine sociale il y en a qui
me parlent de musique
Léo lait concernant la musique pour moi
c'est le ces petits biscuits c'est une
il y a un exemple à suivre d'autres qui
parlent voilà on voit les tout ça qui
s'affiche à l'écran la guitare classique
la musique ancienne c'est sa radurie ou
alors il y en a qui posent même des
questions j'aime uniquement la musique
rap mais le concept du rap m'échappe
complètement heureusement qu'on peut
aimer quelque chose sans parfaitement le
comprendre en connaître tous les tenants
et aboutissants il y a une question que
j'ai trouvé intéressante et qui revient
un peu à ce dont on parlait à l'instant
il y a une question c'est Hugo qui pose
cette question c'est pourquoi le Pass
Culture n'est pas accessible pour les
jeunes de 20 à 25 ans ça pourrait être
intéressant pour le coup à un moment on
a peut-être une plus grande maturité ou
en tout cas on a évolué aussi dans dans
son groupe pour la culture là aussi on
va pas faire comment dire cracher en la
soupe mais il ça ressemble quand même à
l'idée que quand on est adolescent
puisque là il était tendu c'est ça au
16-17 ans enfin on est déjà un
consommateur de culture c'est à dire
qu'on a déjà un rapport économique à la
culture ce qui est d'ailleurs est un peu
ironique parce que les jeunes avec les
réseaux sociaux ont accès la culture
largement gratuite c'est à dire
téléchargement de musique échange de
fichiers etc mais bon imaginons
consommateur alors qu'il aurait été plus
logique d'imaginer des activités
collectives communes gratuites ou pas
mais payées par l'État sans qu'il y a
déboursé soi-même jusqu'à la majorité et
que une fois qu'on devient justement
indépendant enfin si on peut l'être
alors qu'on est un rapport de
consommateur mais si jeune il vaudrait
mieux moi je dirais acteur c'est pour ça
hors de la culture c'est-à-dire la
fabriquer
du Pass Culture et les actions qui sont
menées par certains établissements avec
des classes c'est là que ça devient
quand même intéressant de le dispositif
un petit peu évolué en quelques années
après encore une fois c'est pouvoir
s'appuyer sur à l'intérieur des
établissements sur des enseignants et
sur des personnes qui sont elles-mêmes
motivées pour faire découvrir autre
chose donc ça implique de passer par un
tiers aussi la médiation
j'estime que si on est on passe sans
transition de l'âge adolescent à l'âge
adulte de ce côté acteur
la consommation de la culture certes on
peut on peut déplorer qu'on soit un
consommateur dès le plus adolescent mais
on a on s'habitue aussi avec cette
version du passe culture à soi-même
alloué
bah voilà un certain budget à la culture
et de la même manière qu'on le fera
quand on est adulte je trouve que c'est
une forme d'éducation et que la
transition si on était si on avait accès
gratuitement en tant que jeune
adolescent a des activités payées par
l'État mais qu'ensuite à l'âge de 18 ans
et qu'il fallait se retrouver soi-même à
allouer ces fonds là peut-être que on
perdrait cette habitude ce réflexe par
ce qu'on se dit bah c'est plus gratuit
j'y vais plus je suis d'accord voilà je
veux juste insister sur le fait que il
ne faudrait pas que le Pass Culture soit
une façon de reproduire les inégalités
culturelles qui font que voilà que ce
dans certains milieux on ira
naturellement vers un gadget voilà ou
quelque chose de pas intéressant dans
d'autres on fera on ira du côté d'une
pratique parce qu'on sait que on peut
être sujet et fabriqué de la culture et
dans d'autres on ira allez pour faire le
bon élève et bien s'entendre avec les
parents vers une culture plus légitime
mais donc il faudrait pas que c'est
différence là soit reproduite par le
bascule donc oui oh parce que tu aies
compris le consommateur adolescent mais
couplé à une vraie politique publique et
de terrain parce qu'il y a pas que
l'État d'incitation à tout ça et surtout
de pratique et découverte politique de
tout ça on va en parler tout ça la
culture doit pas être détaché de la
politique il faut pas que ce soit une
liste d'oeuvre sinon c'est ennuyeux il y
a des grandes différences effectivement
de pratiques culturelles il y a
peut-être des institutions qui sont plus
intimides que d'autres selon son milieu
social selon son histoire familiale sans
doute que la plus intimidante des
institutions et bien c'est l'Opéra de
Paris l'Opéra Bastille l'Opéra Garnier
pour lever les freins les réticences et
surtout attirer les jeunes la saison
dernière l'institution envers 10 de ces
spectacles aux jeunes de moins de 28 ans
qui ont pu bénéficier du tarif de 10
euros pour découvrir les opéras en
avant-première regardez ce reportage de
Cécile sixsu
c'est un lieu que l'on croit réservé à
une certaine élite pourtant depuis 2015
l'Opéra Bastille ouvre ses portes aux
jeunes publics plusieurs spectacles
chaque année sont réservés au moins de
28 ans pour 10 euros Angelo étudiant
vient pour la première fois assister à
la répétition générale de Roméo et
Juliette il espère que l'expérience
changera son regard sur l'opéra c'est
quelque chose de long et un peu chiant
désolé du terme mais quelque chose d'un
peu long chien mais je sais pas c'est ça
peut pas être si long ici chiant que ça
si autant de personnes s'y intéressent
et si c'est aussi connu manuel est venu
grâce à Hélène déjà initié j'ai pas eu
beaucoup d'occasions d'aller à l'opéra
depuis que je suis adulte quand j'étais
plus petit que mes parents donc c'était
gros dodo devant le spectacle et là
j'espère que on va profiter quoi moi ce
que j'attends c'est que j'ai vu un seul
opéra et c'était dans une langue
étrangère avec des sur titrages
étrangers donc j'avais pas compris même
l'histoire
c'est pas très familière et comme là
c'est Roméo et Juliette qu'en plus c'est
en français ben j'espère me plonger
d'autant plus dans l'histoire ce soir là
ils sont plus de 2000 jeunes dans la
salle un succès pour la directrice
marketing dont l'objectif est de faire
découvrir cet art un nouveau public ça
fait vraiment partie notre politique
globale pour attirer des jeunes publics
et de renouveler les publics de l'Opéra
de leur donner la possibilité de venir
essayer cette expérience pour leur
donner envie après de revenir avec des
amis plus tard avec leurs enfants
le Roméo et Juliette mise en scène par
Thomas joli débute par une scène de bal
masqué au pied du grand escalier
d'apparat les capulés fêtent
l'anniversaire de Juliette
[Musique]
une oeuvre classique avec une mise en
scène parfois spectaculaire
[Musique]
au gré de la romance des amants le décor
devient balcon chapelle puis chambre à
coucher des costumes la mise en scène et
le jeu d'acteur des chanteurs offrent
une modernité au chef-d'œuvre de Charles
Gounod
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la fin le public d'initié est conquis
impressionné par la musique les
chorégraphies la scène qui était qu'une
seule scène mais grâce à ses mouvements
le fait que la scène pouvait tourner sur
elle-même on était à un seul endroit
mais en même temps on était transporté à
plusieurs endroits en même temps ça
c'était vraiment incroyable et
franchement bah je reviendrai ça c'est
sûr une offre qui a quand même été
retranscrit dans pas mal de spots quoi
enfin au cinéma enfin de passer une
pièce de théâtre mais voir ça à l'Opéra
c'est vraiment sympa pour le coup
j'étais assez bluffé par les décors
notamment comment ça jouer quoi la pièce
qui tournait adapté au bon moment moi
j'étais assis surprise de la modernité
des costumes enfin je m'attendais pas du
tout à ça enfin c'est sûr que quand j'ai
vu la toute première scène et que j'ai
vu voilà ce décor très moyenâgeux après
je m'attendais pas à voir tout d'un coup
des gens en paillettes et tout pour le
ténor Benjamin qui interprète Roméo
jouait devant ce jeune public lui
procure des sensations différentes alors
un public jeune c'est absolument
incroyable parce que ça fait 10 fois
plus de bruit qu'un public normal il y a
une effervescence et surtout il y a on
sent un plaisir et un bonheur d'être là
que je dois dire on sent pas dans les
autres représentations donc on se donne
à fond parce que c'est vraiment notre
vraie première et on voit que il y a
toujours une réception assez incroyable
avec avec le public jeune c'était
extraordinaire d'entendre leur réaction
à la fin une sortie de scène tragique
très applaudie
voilà la preuve que l'opéra peut trouver
son public jeune à travers ses
opérations est-ce que vous avez autour
de vous des jeunes qui disent l'opéra
c'est pas pour moi la musique classique
en ce type de réticence bien sûr qu'il y
a plein de jeunes qui pensent que
l'opéra c'est pas accessible pour eux
mais comme on a pu le voir avec ce jeune
qui a dit au début c'est nul et chiant
et que à la fin a dit c'est génial je
reviendrai donc il a il a découvert il a
apprécié il y retournera avec ses amis
donc je pense que celui d'une expérience
il suffit d'une expérience une mise en
contact il suffit surtout qu'on donne
qu'on offre notamment avec le passe
culture la curiosité aux jeunes d'aller
et de découvrir justement l'opéra pour
que il se dise qu'ils y retourneront
avec plaisir oui toute la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à les
orienter du coup aussi vers d'autres
choses mais est-ce que même question
quand même est-ce que vous pensez que
l'opéra c'est intimidant oui bien sûr
c'est intimidant l'opéra l'institution
la durée le
séchant qui sont
enfin des gens qu'on a pas l'habitude
d'entendre des voix qu'on appelle
l'habitude d'entendre je pense que
l'école a un rôle fondamental dans
l'éducation et c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
ce reportage les personnes qui avaient
été voir de l'Opéra avant l'âge adulte
l'avait été souvent avec leurs
enseignants c'est mon cas aussi et pour
que le Pass Culture permette enfin en
tout cas pour qu'on utilise le Pass
Culture à l'Opéra il faut qu'au
qu'auparavant on est déjà été
sensibilisé à ça il faut qu'on ait été
le voir et si le milieu familial ne le
permet pas parce que voilà pour des
raisons de sociales souvent l'école doit
jouer ce rôle là moi je trouve que le
jeune a un peu tout dit quand il dit
c'est long c'est chiant et voilà on peut
s'endormir je pense qu'il y a il y a un
enjeu vraiment de de confort aussi c'est
pas possible d'être concurrentiel face
au cinéma face à la SVOD aux plateformes
de streaming etc si on est mal assis si
on a pas d'espace pour ses jambes si on
a les sur titrage qui était mentionnés
qui sont comme je l'ai été récemment à
l'Opéra Bastille à gauche à droite ou en
haut et qu'on a mal à la nuque parce
qu'on est trois heures installée c'est
l'État est pratique c'est très concret
en fait ça paraît simple dit comme ça
mais ça joue sur l'expérience qu'on a de
de ce temps là et la première expérience
c'est souvent la bonne pour le meilleur
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire cette
expérience
qui est faite à l'Opéra cette opération
donc c'est place à 10 euros en
avant-première c'est utile d'utiliser le
levier tarifaire c'est un très bon point
de départ effectivement de d'avoir un
tarif très accessible mais c'est pas
suffisant effectivement le fait de
pouvoir créer le désir de venir se
rendre dans ces lieux déjà il faut
savoir que les portes de l'Opéra ne
serait-ce que de les pousser l'opéra ou
d'autres structures d'ailleurs ce sont
des portes lourdes on part on parle de
de barrières parfois symbolique bien sûr
pour se rendre dans des lieux mais il
faut savoir que il faut aussi les
pousser les portes physiquement et
concrètement je crois que ce qui est
aussi là
intéressant pour pour le travail qu'on
mène en tant que médiateur médiateur
culturel c'est que c'est mon travail
mais c'est le travail de plein d'autres
personnes qui sont pas forcément dans
des théâtres qui sont dans des
associations je pense à l'association
3027 qui travaille dans les quartiers du
18e moi je m'appuie beaucoup sur des
personnes comme ça sur des encore une
fois sur des éducateurs sur des
formateurs dans des associations de
personnes qui viennent d'arriver en
France parce que c'est aussi intéressant
d'avoir des publics jeunes cette tranche
d'âge
15-30 ans on pourrait dire qui qui n'est
pas forcément habitué à venir à réserver
ses places là à la fin c'est très beau
il dit c'est un public qui fait du bruit
qui a plus d'enthousiasme qui applaudit
peut-être plus fort et que ça fait du
bien accueilli dans une salle aussi
c'est très important à savoir est-ce
qu'on va lui réserver un quota de place
à la troisième balcon est-ce que il va
être mélangé avec d'autres spectateurs
et donc pas stigmatiser en quelque sorte
tout ça ça compte énormément dans
l'accueil et dans l'expérience qu'on
peut faire de sa sortie dans un lieu
culturel et on y est très attentif quand
on travaille dans les structures j'avais
été frappé de voir par exemple sur
Twitter des enseignantes qui se qui
déploraient des accueils
désagréables qui avaient été ceux de
grands musées français parisiens le
citer parce que je suis pas certain
duquel c'était mais quand on a des
classes qui viennent de banlieue
parisienne qui sont peut-être un peu
plus bruyantes que les spectateurs
traditionnels et ça va s'ils sont mal
accueillis par les visiteurs déjà qui
viennent pas forcément souvent à Paris
ils ont cette expérience qui est très
fréquent ça que vous quand vous arrivez
avec une classe dans une dans un aller
voir une pièce de théâtre que le public
se manifeste soit c'est désagréable
d'ailleurs souvent des petits mots des
mots de la part de jeunes d'élèves qui
nous remercient de l'accueil qui leur a
été fait par exemple à la Maison de la
poésie ou dans d'autres ça veut dire que
tu n'as pas supplémentaire aussi pour
qu'ils se sentent vraiment ils sont très
sensibles c'est important de réduire
cette fracture culturelle dont on parle
aussi il faut qu'il se passe quelque
chose c'est ça qui compte et pas
uniquement avec l'opéra le le Pierre
Bourdieu qu'on qu'on hante un peu ce
débat disait quand même que il disait le
l'opéra c'est l'exemple même de la bonne
volonté culturelle j'adore l'expression
c'est-à-dire tout le monde classe
défavorisée culturellement comme
bourgeoisie culturelle c'est qu'il faut
aimer l'opéra c'est c'est une forme
supérieure qui faut aimer mais comme
c'est un il faut aimer du coup si on est
voilà donc si on peut casser ça
effectivement on y invitant des gens qui
trouvent un intérêt par ailleurs tiens
déjà qui font des liens avec des formes
musicales des formes théâtrales mais
mais on en reste pas à l'Opéra il y a
d'autres formes qui auront le même effet
parce que le spectacle vivant
effectivement est en plein déclin
l'opération d'ailleurs presque mieux que
le reste mais si c'est un opéra rock si
c'est une lecture de slam poétique si
c'est du théâtre de rue ou de la danse
contemporaine qui ont besoin aussi voilà
de d'une type à sculpture ça peut aussi
changer de Starmania on peut avoir des
metteurs en scène contemporains très
pointues qui vont venir aussi prendre
des œuvres très populaires et là on peut
faire aussi
vraiment des passerelles quoi c'est
vraiment l'opéra c'est le plaisir d'y
être allé donc peu importe ceux qui ont
y a vu c'est un peu voilà on a poussé la
porte comme vous dites mais voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière la porte
mais il y a aussi la possibilité de
donner les plateaux à ces jeunes gens
pourquoi pas en lien avec des artistes
enfin il y a de plus en plus de projets
participatifs enfin participatif étant
un peu un mot voilà pas de passe partout
mais d'occupation du lieu parce que ça
pose aussi la question de l'offre
finalement qu'est-ce que on va aller
découvrir sur les plateaux en ce sens
les unes galantes de Clément cogitor à
l'Opéra ça a été quand même tellement ça
crée vraiment du plaisir chez tout type
de public et voilà c'est que le lieu
d'un coup peut devenir aussi accessible
voilà avec des costumes de de rue des
rappeurs etc enfin dans les coursives
enfin partout dans tout le pas sur la
chaîne justement horsen quoi et le fond
aussi je pense que enfin effectivement
la le lieu doit être un peu décloisonné
mais moi j'avais été marqué à au lycée
de enfin comprendre la métamorphose de
Kafka parce que
professeur nous avait expliqué
l'histoire du de France 4k avec son père
après avoir lu l'oeuvre je savais pas
compris auparavant je pense que de la
manière à l'Opéra avoir peut-être une
offre un peu nouvelle où on a un
contexte une introduction au début sur
la visite de Nixon en Chine qui est le
dernier opéra que je suis allé voir à
Bastille si on sait pas qui est si on
sait pas bien qui est Nixon si on
comprend pas bien le contexte d'une
visite américaine on comprend pas en
fait et voilà voir peut-être un sous
texte qui est ouvert au spectateur 10 15
minutes avant ou les jeunes peuvent être
emmenés je pense que c'est c'est une
belle manière de faire par exemple on
parle de musique classique et comme je
rebondis sur les commentaires que on a
eu sur sur votre compte il y a eu
beaucoup de jeunes qui parlent de leur
amour de la musique classique voilà je
suis jeune j'ai 24 ans j'aime écouter de
la musique classique j'adore l'opéra
Olga écouter du classique quand je bosse
du rap US quand je cours et sinon je lis
des livres de cuisine très important
aussi et sinon Estelle violoncelle et ça
ça revient un peu à ce que vous vous
disiez je viens d'avoir mon Master en
violoncelle donc musique classique mais
j'aime bien écouter plein plein d'autres
choses donc aussi cette dimension de la
pratique qui peut mener aussi à la
culture parce que c'est quand même une
communauté qui est une de niche déjà
intéressée par la culture c'est un
sélection là qui est pas du tout facile
de la population
mais bien sûr ce sont des jeunes qui
sont intéressés par la culture parce que
c'est le compte de Jules qui dit bien
sûr sa passion pour les expos la culture
etc sur son compte c'est très important
de le préciser on parlait un peu de
comment peut-être donner du contexte aux
oeuvres et on va arriver peut-être à la
partie qui est peut-être la partie qui
va faire le plus débat sur ce plateau
c'est le débat qu'on va consacrer à la
cancel culture au mouvement on va faire
attention aux mots qu'on utilise donc la
question c'est faut-il ajuster changer
avertir sur les oeuvres du passé pour
les adapter à l'évolution de notre
société notamment pour ne pas heurter la
jeunesse ses attentes sa sensibilité
donc tout ça ça fait débat et on va en
parler sur ce plateau et pour cela on va
accueillir Mathias Arai
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour Tom alors
Mathias vous allez nous parler de cancel
culture je mets des guillemets sur cette
expression car l'expression en elle-même
déjà fait débat voilà cette expression
qui hérite le poil de certains et qui
est porté comme un étendard par d'autres
la cancer culture ou la culture de
l'annulation est un phénomène venu des
États-Unis qui se base sur le boycott du
neuvre d'un artiste ou d'un courant
artistique en réalité c'est une
expression un peu fourre-tout dans
laquelle entre également le fait de
déboulonner des statuts ou de changer
des titres de livres puisqu'on part d'un
postulat celui qu'on ne peut pas
célébrer dans l'espace public une
personne ayant commis au cours de sa vie
un fait moralement répréhensible ou qui
en tout cas choque un gros pour une
communauté alors initialement très
orientée vers le racisme anti noir l'un
quand c'est le cultures c'est peu à peu
étendu dans les luttes féministes ou
encore LGBT plus ou ta outletic avant
d'arriver en France je peux peut-être
vous donner quelques exemples thèmes
Pépé le putois vous vous souvenez tous
autour de la table de ce personnage des
Looney Toons c'est bien il a été quand
seul ou annulé du dernier space car
accusé de participer à la culture du
viol un deuxième exemple vous connaissez
tous Agatha Christie et bien son dernier
livre son livre dipty et bien dans
sa dernière édition en France changement
de titre et place à ils étaient 10 alors
quelle est la ligne des opposants à la
Cancale culture quelle est leur ligne de
défense il s'agirait selon eux d'une
attaque à la liberté d'expression en
juillet 2020 150 personnalités du monde
universitaire de la culture des
intellectuels si une tribune dans la
revue américaine Harper's Magazine parmi
les signataires on retrouve l'écrivaine
britanniques JK Rowling elle-même
victime de cancel culture ou encore le
linguiste libertaire américain Noam
Chomsky alors dans leur lettre cette
phrase la manière de vaincre les idées
mauvaises et de les exposer de les
argumenter et de les persuader et non
d'essayer de les faire taire ou de les
faire disparaître un avis que partage
uber Eckman maître de conférences en
lettres modernes à l'Université de Rouen
est-ce qu'on veut transmettre cette
culture en transmettant également les
outils qui permettront
qui permettront aux étudiants ou aux
élèves de les critiquer par eux-mêmes ou
est-ce qu'on veut protéger la jeunesse
en filtrant en empêchant en empêchant
les lecteurs de lire par exemple les
textes originaux d'une œuvre même s'ils
peuvent choquer
un climat inquiétant comme le dit
certains alors c'est vrai que quand on
voit cette une de L'Express d'octobre
2020 tais-toi ou disparaît on peut se
dire que les choses sont graves mais
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment parler de
censure pour autant alors j'ai interrogé
leur mural est essayiste et historienne
elle a écrit un ouvrage qui s'intitule
qui annule quoi et selon elle on en fait
peut-être un poil trop on en fait
beaucoup trop c'est un sujet polémique
qui excite beaucoup les journalistes en
particulier qui vous sommes toujours de
vous qui vous demande toujours si on est
pour ou on est contre s'agit pas d'être
pour ou contre la quinze au caoutchouc
ou le ouisme comme on dit en France mais
d'analyser ce qui est en jeu c'est à
dire le soulèvement d'une génération qui
ne qui qui refuse le monde tel qu'il est
c'est pas la quinte qui menace la
civilisation
dans son ouvrage leur muraille explique
par exemple que des Boulonnais des
statues ne date pas d'hier mais bien du
sac de rhum au 16e siècle ou encore que
lorsque des groupes féministes demandent
leur retrait d'un film de Roman Polanski
par exemple et bien les opposants crient
à la censure mais que dans les faits
bien les films sont bien la fiche merci
merci beaucoup Mathias je sais pas si on
fait ce débat parce qu'on est
journaliste et si nous excite pour cette
raison mais on va quand même essayer de
d'en parler sur ce plateau François
Cusset qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
c'est un sujet dont vous parlez dans
votre tract la haine de l'émancipation
vous parler de ce mouvement donc on
entend souvent dans la sphère médiatique
des offensives qui dénoncent le wokisme
la cancel culture et vous vous dites
tout ça c'est un épouvantail c'est un
fétiche politique on raconte n'importe
quoi on est en plein délire et leur
Murat absolument raison c'est ça on en
fait trop parce que ça va d'ailleurs pas
seulement du débat télévisé ça vend de
l'algorithme parce que ça polarise la
réseaux sociaux les gens s'engueulent et
puis ça polarise politiquement quand
même un terrain de confrontation
idéologique très direct mais non moi ce
qui m'insupporte c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait ce petit tract c'est là quand c'est
le colchor le wok Kiss c'est le tout
réunir une la sensibilité extrêmement
variée d'une nouvelle génération une
sensibilité plus grande qu'avant à la
question de discrimination grâce à cette
sensibilité on a progressé c'est à dire
qu'on a pas le même humour on fait pas
les mêmes blagues on fait attention à
des choses etc mais à l'intérieur de
cette immense génération et mondiale en
plus bien sûr qu'il y a des gens qui
vont jusqu'au bout et qui vont trop loin
qui sont sûrs d'autres qui sont plus
modérés etc il y a pas de Cannes seul
couche en soi et je rappelle tout de
suite une chose c'est que s'il y a des
gens qui gagnent son il y a au moins
deux sources du canne sans le canne sans
c'est l'extrême droite qui aux
États-Unis dans la bibliothèques
municipales interdit les romanciennois
la bande dessinée sur la Shoah etc vous
voyez euh Spiegelman on peut on peut pas
le lire au Texas donc là et le marché
que fait le marché le marché c'est une
forme de censure le marché reçoit
plusieurs manuscrits reçoit plusieurs
offres plusieurs projets et dit ça ça va
marcher non ça c'est un peu trop
exigeant on prendra
la censure elle est du marché et des
conservateurs après qu'il y ait des
jeunes qui soient sur ces questions un
peu trop sensibles et bon et pour finir
là-dessus moi je place ma barrière
morale personnelle du côté de l'oeuvre
s'il y a de l'oeuvre qui est déjà publié
qui existe qui est du passé qu'elle soit
écrite ou musicale etc est à la fois une
œuvre et un document du passé et en tant
que document du passé il ne faut
absolument pas le modifier sinon c'est
effectivement l'histoire qu'on réécrit
voilà et à la limite j'irai jusqu'à dire
les statues des de la
colonisation si on les enlève tous
Comment saura-t-on qu'il y a eu
colonisation donc voilà il faut garder
il faut contextualiser il faut peut-être
mais pas tout changer mais soyons subtil
c'est pas tout ou rien c'est à dire oui
qu'on est renommé qu'on est retiré les
dipty parce qu'ils étaient
lissent d'abord c'est le type d'origine
il y a pas de dans le petit Agatha
Christie etc oui la langue évolue avec
les époques bien sûr pourquoi pas faire
faire les sardinitouses autour de ça
bien sûr que non il faut que ça soit
plus subtil que ça Jules alors pourquoi
est-ce que je suis d'accord globalement
avec le propos évidemment je pense qu'on
en fait un peu trop mais nous au crayon
on a essayé de se constituer en tant que
média qui rassemble des personnes qui se
serait pas croisé sur notre
intermediaire sur notre intermédiation
parce qu'on estime que c'est important
pour la démocratie que les algorithmes
de réseaux sociaux montrent des contenus
auxquels on adhère pas et donc on est
une confrontation de débat d'idées sur
la sur la question des oeuvres je suis
d'accord voilà on se place du côté de
l'oeuf c'est un document historique mais
alors parfois il y a des des sujets où
on est un peu la frontière il y a cet
exemple à la Sorbonne en 2019 d'une
pièce d'échine donc qui est un
antique qui a été censuré enfin en tout
cas qui a été annulé parce que il y
avait des accusations de Blackface des
personnages blancs qui s'étaient
maquillés avec un maquillage sombre moi
je trouve que c'est voilà c'est là on
est à une frontière il y a quelque chose
qui est en fait le problème c'est qu'on
en parle c'est-à-dire que bien sûr je
veux dire que tout le monde est d'accord
que on ne peut pas empêcher la
représentation d'une pièce sous ce
prétexte là même si ce prétexte-là est
un est un objet d'un débat politique
tout à fait intéressant qui a un débat
qui relève de la communauté
afro-américaine leur lutte pour les
droits civiques est-ce que les Noirs ont
droit d'être joué par les Blancs c'est
un drake question mais de là empêcher
l'importation on n'empêche rien je suis
d'accord mais c'est simple anecdote
cette représentation empêché il y a
maintenant 4 ans mais y a-t-il un jour
ou un média un magazine émission de télé
n'en fait pas une honnêtement on monte
en épargne des histoires oui évidemment
on est d'accord des exemples JK Rowling
qui est pas invité au 20 ans de d'Harry
Potter parce qu'on l'accuse de
trampoline en boucle quand même
ah ben on va continuer à en parler mais
allez-y je suis assez d'accord avec vous
je trouve qu'on en fait beaucoup trop
avec le hoquisme avec la teinte ciel
culture aujourd'hui je pense que il y a
une génération qui proteste et qui
réfléchit à l'histoire et qui réfléchit
à la culture autour de soi et je trouve
que c'est quelque chose de bien et il
faut une réflexion collective
accompagnée par des politiques aussi et
pour trouver pour trouver une réponse
assez protestations c'est aussi
j'insiste parce que ça se relie au début
de l'émission c'est aussi comme ça que
la nouvelle génération s'approprie la
parole le discours son regard sur le
passé les oeuvres de la culture alors
oui ça va trop loin c'est l'idée de
vouloir réécrire le texte d'une œuvre
non ça on peut pas quoi vous savez je
sais pas quand on traduit Shakespeare on
retravit j'expire tous les 20 ans parce
que la langue et bah ouais on peut
pourquoi pas en slam en rap et parce que
après tout c'est aussi toute la le génie
d'avoir chopé la vulgarité d'une époque
et de la voix d'en avoir fait d'être
magnifique
avait parfois une langue très très
réunion excellente donc oui on peut
retraduire mais on ne réécrit pas non on
ne refait pas une œuvre et on ne cache
pas une œuvre à nos regards offensés
sous prétexte voilà de ces questions là
on va quand même parler de la question
de de la censure voire de l'autocensure
et de c'est un peu vous avez commencé à
aborder nous sommes avec avec Agnès
Tricoire bonjour
vous êtes avocate spécialiste en
propriété intellectuelle et
co-responsable de l'Observatoire de la
liberté de création déjà un mot sur ce
qu'est votre observatoire et qui il
regroupe s'il vous plaît
alors on a fondé l'Observatoire au début
des années 2000 à l'occasion de la
recrudescence de membres de censure
contre des œuvres et Manon non plus
exclusivement de l'extrême droite qui
est toujours extrêmement active mais
aussi d'organisation de défense de
l'enfant contre des œuvres d'art
contemporain
des nouvelles associations d'extrême
droite contre des films il y a une
activité extrêmement intense d'une
association qui est minuscule par
exemple et qui a mis en coupe réglé le
cinéma et la production
cinématographique en France ce que très
peu de gens savent et ça au nom de la
protection de l'enfance donc nous avons
une activité l'Observatoire rassemble et
c'est un des seuls lieux c'est un lieu
un peu unique pour ça de façon
complètement transversale tous les
genres artistiques existants et tout le
monde est solidaire c'est à dire que
quand un livre est censuré et bien les
musiciens les artistes interprètent la
Ligue des droits de l'homme à
l'initiative de l'aventure la Ligue de
l'enseignement aussi tout le monde est
solidaire et personne ne peut opposer un
message ça m'intéresse pas parce que
c'est un livre alors que moi je fais
autre chose donc c'est un lieu d'échange
extrêmement important dans lequel il y a
une quinzaine et bientôt
17 et 18 organisations parce que tout le
monde vous nous rejoindre en ce moment à
cause de la montée d'extrême droite de
façon très claire avec tout ce qui se
passe lors des concerts notamment vous
avez vu un peu partout en France que ça
soit à l'est ou en Bretagne il y a des
bandes de néo-nazis qui essaient
d'interdire des des spectacles
soi-disant parce qu'ils sont sacrilège
souvent il s'agit de mieux qui sont
désaffectés du culte de pied extrêmement
longtemps moi c'est comme ça que je suis
venu aux questions de censure en tant
qu'avocate parce qu'on poursuivait un
artiste plasticien qui intervenait dans
une chapelle la Carpentras et qu'on que
la mairie de l'époque avait considéré
que c'était sacrilège et voulait que
finalement il allait faire son
installation dans le gymnase
oui au mois de janvier vous vous étiez
ému de déprogrammation ça ça rejoint ce
que disait Jules vous il y avait la
déprogrammation des amandiers de Valeria
bruneté Deski une pièce de théâtre je
crois que c'était au Théâtre 13 ou une
comédienne 6 genre interprété une
transgenre ou encore et bien le cas qui
a été énormément
dont on a énormément parlé dans les
médias celui de Bastien Vivès au
Festival d'Angoulême est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer vous ce qui vous a
posé problème dans toutes ces
déprogrammations et puis peut-être aussi
répondre à ce que disait François Cusset
qui dit on en fait trop sur sur ces
sujets
alors moi je crois qu'on en fait pas
trop et que notre raison d'être c'est
d'indiquer quand ça ne va pas quand la
limite est franchie quand on déprogramme
une pièce parce que elle ne devrait pas
être jouée par une personne qui n'a pas
le bon sexe la bonne couleur de la bonne
couleur de peau on fait quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave qui est de de
d'abord de dénir la personne qui a
travaillé le droit de montrer son
travail pour une raison qui lui échappe
complètement dont elle dont elle est
absolument pas mettre et c'est de la
discriminer c'est une forme de
discrimination donc c'est un tolérable
je je dois préciser que nous tous à
l'observatoire toutes les organisations
qu'il compose sont extrêmement sensibles
aux questions des discriminations
simplement il y a des lignes jaunes qui
ne faut pas franchir le communiqué que
nous avons diffusé hier concerne la
tournée de deux par Dieu
Depardieu et poursuivi il est poursuivi
il est il est mis en examen pour viol
extrêmement grave il y a à nouveau 13
femmes qui ont témoigné contre lui dans
un média et non pas devant la justice
mais les organisations féministes qui
ont écrit au maire
pour demander que sa tournée soit
annulée que ces concerts soient annulés
se trompe de moyens elles ont raison de
ne pas être contentes elles ont
parfaitement le droit d'appeler au
boycott qui est parfaitement légitime
parce que chacun a le droit en
conscience de décider ce qu'il va voir
ou pas et le public est citoyen et
responsable mais on ne peut pas juger en
ces lieux à les places et quand une
œuvre est programmée elle doit avoir
lieu ça c'est la ligne jaune qui est
maintenant définie par la loi loi que
nous avons aidé à faire voter en 2016 et
qui maintenant protège comme une liberté
fondamentale la liberté de création et
de diffusion des œuvres restez avec nous
parce que ça serait intéressant que vous
restiez avec nous sur la suite de ce
débat qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire
c'est des programmations améliorer ses
biens donc de lieu culturels
parfois ils anticipent des problèmes ou
en réponse à des polémiques ces
différentes à cette question c'est quand
même très complexe comme comme question
simplement je pense que ça pose bien sûr
que la l'expérience l'expérience a une
valeur l'expérience d'avoir vécu une
situation dans sa chair
c'est indéniable c'est une valeur très
forte pour prendre la parole pour être
sur scène mais il faut aussi sur scène
où exposer dans un livre ou toute forme
d'armée je pense que le chemin qu'un
artiste peut faire pour approcher aussi
tout simplement une expérience qui n'est
pas la sienne si cet artiste a une
sensibilité si c'est un bel artiste un
grand artiste mais c'est super
intéressant aussi de voir le chemin qui
est fait pour approcher l'autre dans sa
singularité et on n'a pas besoin d'être
pour représenter ce travail peut-être
même de l'artiste en tout cas je pense
moi
cette valeur de du chemin de l'approche
en tout cas pour pour se connecter à
l'autre on a tous une expérience humaine
enfin c'est ce qui nous c'est ce qu'on a
en commun et l'artiste enfin c'est tout
de même sans rôle c'est son travail
après ça pose la question de la qualité
de cette travail artistique ou pas et
sur des programmations sur le fait qu'il
y ait des institutions qui
voilà des programmes alors que ce soit
quelques institutions ou beaucoup mais
en tout cas qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire ça j'avoue sur ce plan là c'est
quelque chose sur lequel je ne serai pas
vraiment répondre parce qu'il y a des
enjeux souterrains qui sont
qui m'échappent aussi parfois à
l'endroit moi où je suis puisque je ne
suis pas programmatrice enfin je pense
que c'est extrêmement complexe de
prendre des décisions il y a beaucoup de
d'hystéries de d'instrumentalisation de
récup enfin on récupère aussi c'est ces
sujets donc
ce sont des questions complexes
je pense que voilà il y a des enjeux
financiers parfois qu'il faut aussi
entendre de la part des acteurs et en
même temps la position de principe entre
entre les deux il faut c'est à chacun de
trancher moi je pense que je suis
d'accord vraiment sur cette cette aspect
nécessaire qu'à l'art cette valeur de
de dire l'impossible de dire l'interdit
de de trancher enfin j'ai sur le créer
on a fait une interview de Yann Moix
l'écrivain qui me disait un bon livre
c'est une lame qui ouvre et qui et qui
parfois fait mal mais on a besoin
d'avoir des oeuvres qui sont exigeantes
et oui après il faut que les festivals
assument ou les de manière générale
quand même cette difficulté et qui est
une éducation critique aussi au du
public pour pour accepter que parfois
une œuvre soit difficile à intégrer et
quand c'est des œuvres du passé qu'on
puisse avoir l'appareil critique aussi
de les interpréter moi j'étais choqué il
y a quelques temps de lire Isaac Asimov
qui ce projet dans le futur c'est de la
science-fiction il y a pas une femme
dans tout son roman on est dans les
années 50
ou de lire les messages malgré lui de
Molière et en fait ce ghanaël bah sa
femme et c'est normal bon voilà c'est
c'est les choses ils font un peu
critique pour les décrypter
ouais non mais l'idée de programmation
personne ne peut être pour de manière
générale mais il faut ajouter
immédiatement alors si on dit ok faut
pas déprogrammer parce que c'est pas la
bonne méthode il faut ajouter
immédiatement un ce que rappelait maître
Tricoire qui est que effectivement ce
qui est le plus fréquent par exemple
dans les festivals en France ou dans les
œuvres qui sont jouées aujourd'hui c'est
le risque d'une annulation par l'extrême
droite ou à cause de l'extrême droite ou
de bah vous voyez ici
la maison du maire du village donc ils
sont pas d'accord avec les imaginez ce
qu'ils vont faire avec le théâtre ou
avec la MJC etc donc effectivement le
danger est plutôt là maintenant je suis
aussi d'accord avec le fait que c'est
comment dire la méthode n'est pas la
bonne mais l'intention est extrêmement
intéressante donc s'il ne veut pas des
programmer il faut pourtant penser ça
c'est vaste et complexe question
qu'est-ce que c'est que par exemple que
décoloniser les œuvres de notre
patrimoine c'est-à-dire les abordés avec
le regard critique avec la conscience de
toute l'histoire coloniale française
avec le fait qu'on fait plus de place
par exemple en littérature ou en théâtre
aux œuvres venus du monde dit
francophones mais pas la métropole etc
ça voilà et peut-être plus important et
une meilleure méthode qu'effectivement
interdire la présentation d'une femme en
tout cas l'empêcher à cause du Blackface
il faut avertir c'est ça il faut
expliquer contextualiser il y a tout un
travail
je pense qu'il y a un travail il y a un
travail énorme et moi ce qui me ce qui
me choquait dans ce qui a été dit c'est
que pour moi c'est on a le droit de
boycotter on a le droit de dire on veut
pas qui est telle oeuvre mais on n'a pas
le droit de d'interdire une oeuvre de ce
produire et d'être diffuser Agnès Street
word très rapidement peut-être pour un
peu conclure sur sur cette question
je suis très très heureuse d'entendre
des réactions sur le plateau parce qu'on
est tous d'accord et c'est très très
rare qu'on soit tous d'accord sur ces
questions là donc c'est une belle
journée pour pour moi merci
polarisé qui m'aidait pas trop les pour
les contre avec des invectives on est
déjà on est très content de ça merci
beaucoup Agnès Ricard d'avoir participé
à cette émission que je voudrais
conclure mais en donnant des conseils de
lecture quand même c'est ce qu'on vous a
demandé le conseil de lecture au Conseil
d'oeuvre mais vous avez tous choisi des
conseils de lecture isolt qu'est-ce que
vous conseilleriez quel serait votre
recours parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
dit sur les réseaux voilà j'assume ma
quarantaine allez-y alors moi c'est
trouver refuge de Christophe honaudi bio
donc qui est un livre que j'ai beaucoup
aimé d'ailleurs il est journaliste il
écrit quelques quelques articles sur les
pages cultures du point et c'est un
livre qui m'a beaucoup touché sur
justement la censure qui peut se
produire si l'extrême droite monte au
pouvoir et voilà c'est pile poil dans
notre dead vous avez fait exprès
merci beaucoup du coup également donc
jus de vous quel était votre votre
loeuvre que vous avez choisi aussi un
peu en lien avec la discussion du jour
j'ai choisi une œuvre qui est les choses
humaines de karenfield un roman qui est
paru il y a quelques années et qui
traite d'une question cruciale
fondamentale du débat public en ce
moment en France le viol et et voilà
tout la question juridique et politique
autour de ce sujet et je pense que c'est
un livre qui apporte beaucoup de nuances
sur un sujet délicat donc je trouve que
c'est une belle intro entrée en matière
pour quelqu'un qui voudrait un livre
contemporain une histoire donc un roman
et puis sur un thème qu'il concerne je
pense que pour quelqu'un qui lit
relativement peu c'est un livre super à
lire votre Rocco alors moi c'est Chantal
Thomas l'écrivaine Chantal Thomas avec
le livre comment supporter sa liberté
c'est un livre que j'ai découvert dans
ma vingtaine et
qui montre finalement que la jeunesse
c'est aussi un état d'esprit parce que
Chantal Thomas c'est cet état d'esprit
d'un esprit d'indépendance avec aussi
une insolence être curieuse rester
curieux mobile et pour elle et c'est ce
qu'elle montre à travers ce livre qui
est un essai un essai un récit c'est au
fond c'est cette disponibilité cette
disponibilité intérieure à ces
mouvements intérieurs ça va passer par
elle par ça par cette disponibilité et
donc une disponibilité aux autres et au
monde comme il va et en conclu avec vous
François Cusset qu'est-ce que vous avez
choisi moi je voudrais pas plomber
l'ambiance mais il s'agit de d'un livre
qui s'intitule nous fils d'Eichmann de
Gunter unders un type incroyable unders
qui en 1963 a écrit une longue lettre
que voici au fils de Adolf hitchman
alors c'est peut-être je sais pas le
pire personnage du 20e siècle c'est
celui qui a organisé voilà le
l'extermination finale des Juifs c'est
qui est un bureaucrate nazi et donc qui
était pendu pour la retrouver à Jér
problème on l'a pendu et le lendemain
donc il écrit à son fils en lui disant
on va pas être facile d'être le fils de
ce type mais si je peux vous rassurer
sur un point nous sommes tous un peu le
fils d'Eichmann donc c'est aussi un
message voilà la pureté morale n'existe
pas nous sommes tous dans la zone grise
et si des choses aussi horribles
arrivent
interrogeons notre part à tous
responsabilités merci merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre d'avoir participé à
cette émission François Cusset je
rappelle votre tract la haine de
l'émancipation debout la jeunesse du
monde chez gallimara Me est bien la
Maison de la poésie il y a un spectacle
qui s'intitule littérature qui est qui
va nous permettre de découvrir aussi de
vous intéresser Julien ça parle réseaux
sociaux et littérature merci beaucoup à
tous les quatre un nouveau d'avoir
participé à cette émission on se
retrouve très vite dans un nouveau
numéro d'avoir 20 ans très bonne suite
des programmes sur public c'est là
[Musique]